as FBI director James Comey was always
pretty well known but when Donald Trump
fired him last year it boosted his
footprint immeasurably this week he's my
guest here in Berlin where he's
promoting a book even as he faces new
charges of insubordination and violating
procedures in the run-up to the 2016
presidential election so what's the
truth
[Music]
james comey welcome to covered soon
thank you for having me while you're
touring Europe son in your book there's
a storm of criticism in Washington over
actions that you and the FBI took in the
run-up to the presidential election in
2016
most from the Inspector General of the
Justice Department who you politely very
politely told to get lost you didn't
miss anything and you didn't apologize
for anything
are you whiter than white what'd you
mean by that I'm a flawed human I hope
that like we all recognize that we are
and I I meant what I said about the
Inspector General I respect their work I
respect their criticism you just don't
agree with any of them well there's a
fair number of things they said I agree
with but the two big criticisms are
about the two most important decisions I
made and I'd be lying if I said that I
think that criticism is accurate I do
think it's fair though and reasonable
what about the criticism that really
jumped off the page was the department's
revelation that you used a private email
account in violation of official
protocol now for a man who spent a year
and a half investigating Hillary
Clinton's handling of her own email
isn't this hypocrisy it's not but it
does reflect the fact that folks don't
realize what the Clinton investigation
was about it wasn't about her use of a
non-governmental email system it was
about her handling of classified
information and that's a very important
investigation but totally different from
whether you're using it Gmail which I
was using to email drafts of speeches to
myself it was never any accusation that
I used any system to communicate
classified information as inconsistent
with Justice Department policy that's
what they said that's what they said you
broke the rules they said well that's a
good question I don't think they
actually say it that way they say it was
they believe it was inconsistent with
the policy the policy does allow what we
say de minimis use of a private email
system to communicate
I actually think mine was consistent
with that but I'm not gonna fight about
that the important thing is there's a
difference between using a system to
communicate classified content
and using a system and I really don't
see it I really don't see it as a
conflict with the clinton investigation
but i get why the inspector general
included it well not just the inspector
general chuck grassley for instance
chair of the Senate Judiciary Committee
June the 18th he said it's disturbing
that FBI employees tasked with
investigating Secretary Clinton
including the former director appear to
have engaged in strikingly similar
conduct that conduct was on five
occasions you either drafted official
messages on or forwarded emails to your
personal account right yeah I was at the
director for four years and I would
draft speeches for public distribution
send them home to myself so I can work
on the mounted laptop and then send them
back to my government account when I was
completed anybody who thinks that is the
same as the conduct we investigated in
the Clinton case was not paying
attention but there is also an
investigation into how you did handle
classified material take in memos that
you sent outside the FBI okay according
to a Washington Post report shortly
after you were fired in May last year an
FBI review concluded that some of the
information in two of your memos was
classified and that the FBI felt
compelled to retrieve that information
the people you gave it to the
information was marked confidential
apparently the lowest category of
classified but it was classified you
prepared to be investigated oh sure yeah
in fact I've cooperated with them and
talked to them and I eagerly await their
report I think you broke the rules no no
no no no and I think fo you wait for the
report I think what you'll see is I
don't know well y'all go get the answers
I'd answer as I did not in any way and
it's a the reason I want the review done
one of the review don't want the report
out is so that it ends the silliness
about me mishandling classified yeah
yeah review got it wrong then well the
FBI hasn't done a review the FBI
reviewed and declined to investigate for
a mishandling of classified information
the following procedure which is what
they criticized you for violating well
there's no doubt that I
deviated as they say from norms but
there was nothing normal about the
investigation of whether
two candidates for president of the
United States during the election but is
that an excuse for insubordinate and
extraordinary actions which is what they
accused you of no certainly not it's an
it's an explanation as to why how we saw
the decisions and why we chose bad over
worse in each of the key circumstances
they don't accept that choice
well they do they just weigh it
differently they think the better take
take as the decision we had to make
close to the election to tell Congress
we in restarted the investigation the
Inspector General's view is I had a
choice between speaking or not speaking
and I should have not spoken I get that
and I respect that I think that under
ways the damage to the institution that
would have flowed from not speaking
about something that was hugely
important and would have otherwise
covered up a lie that had become no
longer that would cover up a lie that
had hidden from the American people that
we had restarted that investigation okay
I'd like to come on and talk about that
okay the moment but the the accusations
first of all centered on the news
conference you gave in July 2016 which
you announced the FBI would not
recommend criminal charges against
Hillary Clinton you announced it
separately from the Department of
Justice you told them just a few minutes
before you did something I thought in my
entire leadership team thought that was
the way best calculated to protect the
institutions of Justice incredibly
unusual in fact I'd never heard of it
before the FBI announcing separate from
the Department of Justice but given the
situation that the Attorney General was
in my view then what what situation she
was in that the Attorney General was in
the view of a reasonable American
compromised at that point and could
incredibly announce the closure of the
investigation something she implicitly
acknowledged herself by saying she would
accept my recommendation and my view was
and honestly it still is even though I
understand his criticism that if I had
announced it with the Attorney General
the American people would not have had
confidence in the result and the best
although still a bad choice but the best
of the choices was to announce it
separately you said mrs. Clinton's
handling of her emails have been
extremely careless my question to you is
since when is it the job
a federal law enforcement officer to
judge whether politicians or indeed any
citizens behaviors careless our job is
to investigate the conduct of the
subject of the investigation and decide
whether it warrants recommendation for
prosecution but you have to know that
your words would be seized on by the
other side and you used to mrs.
Clinton's disadvantage well I had to
know that my words would be seized on by
everybody which is why I thought so long
and hard about how to describe the
conduct in a way remember the goal in a
way that the American people would have
confidence that it was done in a
competent and independent way when it
came to that July 2016 press conference
the Inspector General said we found none
of his reasons to be a persuasive basis
for deviating from well-established
department policies rhythm this was
showboating this is great for me don't
you think look I knew this was gonna be
bad for me personally this wasn't much
showboating I did one press interview
and one press event in the FBI my final
year and a half and it was that one it
had any knew it would get of course we
were investigating one of the two
candidates for president of the United
States during the election so I get the
Inspector General saying it was a
deviation from normal procedures got it
there was nothing normal about the
situation that's what made it so hard to
figure out what to do given our norms
you're also criticized and you talked a
bit about the October decision also
criticized by the Justice Department
inspector just 11 days before the 2016
election you announced that the
investigation was on again that you'd
found more emails on a laptop belonging
to the husband
a Clinton aide a laptop that the FBI had
located weeks earlier and not bothered
to look at why why the gap in time
why make so long doing nothing if this
was such important information why wait
a month and let it gather dust yeah I
don't know the reason for that I know
that it was discovered in New York
office sometime at the end of September
and that people didn't bring it to me to
ask me to make a decision until the end
of the third week of October it's your
decision
for a man who's always said you want to
stay clear of politics your decision to
reopen the investigation at that late
stage eleven days before the election
wasn't influenced by politics wasn't I
don't remember
thinking about that but I'm asking
myself in my book given the whole world
thought she was gonna be elected
president could that have influenced you
and of course it could I don't think the
decision would have been any different
if Donald Trump was up 20 points in the
polls but I'm asking myself given the
assumption that she was gonna be
president could that I've had an
influence on you sure sure could have
again we tried very hard there's a
difference between considering what the
public thinks and electoral prospects I
don't remember thinking about electoral
prospects explicitly I just don't you
were worried about her coming
illegitimate to the job if you didn't
reopen the investigation the result of
that is Donald Trump is in the white
house drowning in lawsuits directed at
him his foundation just wheezing his
university key members of his campaign
staff indicted and you worried about
mrs. Clinton entering the White House
illegitimate those other things really
are not a concern of mine and they are
as an American citizen but not when
you're director in the FBI making a
decision about an investigation but you
ain't no concerned that she might win
the election no she looked as though she
was and that was one of the factors in
your decision-making process no I hope I
was clear on this I'll say it again I
don't remember ever thinking I have to
make this decision because she's gonna
be elected the question I'm asking
myself in hindsight is given that
everyone thought she was gonna win could
that have influenced me and the answer
is of course it could have I don't
remember it influencing me but again
there's a danger of being reflective I
don't think it would have changed the
decision I think the FBI had to speak
and by the way to correct another thing
you said everyone agreed that we had to
reopen the investigation that was not
the controversial decisions it was
telling everybody exactly what what do
you do 11 days before the election do
you speak about it or do you conceal it
and my judgment was the institution
would suffer horrific damage if we
concealed that it would suffer just bad
damage if we spoke about it but the
effect of
your announcement let me put this to you
was to water down Hillary Clinton's
right to a presumption of innocence
which is a vital part the democratic
justice system and I say this because a
large number of people had to believe
that if you were going to reopen this
investigation and throw this kind of
Boulder into the political waters at
this late stage you had to have
something really important to offer the
public there was really some smoking gun
there that you had and otherwise how
could you possibly justify the risk of
torpedo in her campaign
well again you have to consider where
you were on October the 28th the
Department of Justice in the FBI had
told the American people repeatedly we
finished this investigation there's no
prosecutable case there you can rely on
that American people and that is no
longer true and not in a frivolous way
in a highly significant way which is why
the Department of Justice thought we had
to reopen the investigation so what do
you do reasonable people can see it
differently but my view is you cannot
having spoken about it both the Attorney
General and I and many others had spoken
about it you cannot stay silent in the
face of that information again I've
never imagined a situation like this but
what I ask people is so what would you
do if you were in my shoes and why at
the start of that 11 day period prior to
the election Hillary Clinton was ahead
in the polls by around 6% in the
national polls a week later after your
announcement her lead at half what we
also know is that late deciding voters
went overwhelmingly towards Trump so
there is undoubtedly a case even if it
can't be proved that your action changed
the course of the election you can live
without I'll have to look at that I said
you were mildly nauseous about the
thought you might have impacted the
election I wonder why only mildly well
yes we have to weigh our versions of
nausea but it it makes me slightly sick
to my stomach even now to contemplate
the notion that we had an impact I hope
not but what makes it even more
difficult as it wouldn't change how I
think about it even if I went back in
time it just makes it more painful so I
hope not I hope some day academics
demonstrate that her numbers are already
headed down and
had no impact but honestly it doesn't
change how you have to think about it
sitting in your office on October the
28th it just doesn't 2 days after your
October 28th announcement Senate Senator
Harry Reid wrote to you
it's a complain of a disturbing double
standard for the treatment of sensitive
information his great was that as soon
as you came into possession of the
slightest innuendo related to mrs.
Clinton you you rushed to publicize it
in the most negative light possible he
said and yet you continued to resist his
course to inform the public about
critical information relating to Donald
Trump that's true isn't it
you were inconsistent no and not in any
respect and the premise of his that
would have Maria bent over this but I if
I stay silent on things people later say
I agree to them the notion that all we
had about Hillary Clinton was innuendo
is nonsense but well you possessed he
said explosive information about close
ties and coordination between Donald
Trump his top advisers and the Russian
government yeah that's not true I can't
talk about anything that might be
classified I can just say again that the
characterization of the Senators letter
is not accurate the decision that
President Obama had to make was not my
decision was his was whether to say
something publicly about the Russian
interference effort which is a really
important and close decision the one
that was not close is should we say
something about it about our
intelligence investigation that has just
begun and we don't know what we have so
those are two very different questions
the the President Obama decision was a
hard one you sure by the time that they
made the decision in October to say
something my view was I can avoid action
at this point because the statement is
no longer necessary and yet you still
thought it was worth Hillary Clinton I
know what you mean by zero yeah it was
worth deciding between speaking or
concealing on October the 28th and that
my judgment was we had to speak because
hiding the fact that what we had said in
the summer under oath was no longer true
was an unacceptable outcome so
suspicious were the reports to GCHQ that
the head of the organization flew to
Washington it
at the summer of 2016 to brief the CIA
director John Brennan James clapper the
Director of National Intelligence later
confirmed this flow of information and
intelligence
he said it's sensitive so there was a
lot of sensitive material coming into
you that's no that's not classified
that's no I can say this I disagree with
your preamble I don't believe it to be
accurate but I can't sort for you
because of the rules governing
classified information what's true and
not true a whole lot of reporting about
this is not accurate but I can't go into
it more than that but you didn't worry
at all that if the investigation into
the collusion alleged collusion of the
Trump campaign with the Russians bore
fruit and Donald Trump won the election
his mandate might be illegitimate we
didn't know enough to know whether there
was anything to it so I'd actually don't
even remember thinking about that we
were beginning an investigation we knew
the Russians or the Russians were
messing with our election the separate
question was were any Americans helping
them and we didn't know that at the time
and by the way but you had sex was not a
we had reason to investigate
we knew the Russians were doing
something we had wisps of information
that some Americans might be working
with them didn't know that and again
this is what people sometimes confuse
Hillary Clinton was the subject of that
investigation that opened began publicly
and closed publicly in 2016 Donald Trump
was not the subject of any investigation
during that election it was an
investigation into his campaign
therefore by association that was into
him as well well in a sense it wasn't an
investigation of his campaign it was an
investigation on discreet Americans to
try to see if there's any connection
between the Russian effort and these
people and his campaign well these were
people some of whom were associated with
the campaign but there was not an
investigation of the campaign but
nevertheless even with what you had you
allow tens of millions of Americans to
vote without any of this knowledge what
knowledge is the question I would ask
what what would people have that strong
suspicions that were being passed around
but
the American intelligence community at
that time so the FBI director should
have announced in 2016 that there are
suspicions of wrongdoing by Americans
that was actually never even seriously
considered nobody brought that up and
said we ought to be talking about a
brand new counterintelligence
investigation about Americans that we
don't know whether they've got anything
wrong so I just it I reject the premise
that that was something we should have
disclosed I do think it's an important
question about whether the Obama
administration should have said
something earlier about the Russian
effort but there's no serious argument
we should be talking about a brand-new
counterintelligence case that doesn't
involve the the candidate as a subject
that's just beginning in the summer of
2016 let's don't forget about your
conversations with Donald Trump you you
have this reputation of being a very
tough Washington player you've stood up
to presidents you took on george w bush
and his closest advisors over their
surveillance program and yet with trump
you seem to have been like this awkward
pussycat seemingly unable to tell him a
direct no when he apparently asked you
for your declaration of loyalty you
danced around the subject and then you
came up with this offer of honest
loyalty again in hindsight the things I
think I could do differently and better
but it's a very difficult situation to
be with a brand new President of the
United States alone and so I think even
hindsight it ought to be too tough on
myself I think I handled it in a
reasonable way
you told Trump that he was not
personally under investigation but Anson
was literally true but it was still
inaccurate wasn't it because his
campaign wasn't under investigation
he by association he was under
investigation with it well you know not
in that sense it was it was as you said
technically true literally true but my
general counsel argued that inevitably
we're going to have to look at the
campaign's conduct he's the candidate of
the campaign and so inevitably you're
going to get in a situation where in
some respect his conduct is going to be
reviewed that was his argument to me so
it wasn't a total free pass you were
giving him when you said you're not
under investigation
I was describing something that was
accurate in an effort to defuse a very
not complete well now I don't think
that's the issue of my General Counsel's
concern was we will get to a place it
seems inevitably we'll have to look at
his conduct so will you have to correct
that someday and what does that do when
you create a duty to correct that was
his concern as I recall you were firing
in May last year and wondering why you
were still serving in an administration
led by a man you considered to be a
serial liar you dealt in facts he
clearly didn't deal in facts or
alternative facts it was never going to
end well was it between you and him it
was never gonna be close but that's okay
I was the director of the FBI I was
appointed to a ten-year term and I
thought my duty was to continue to serve
out that term and protect the
institution so yeah it was gonna be
difficult as my interactions with him
during those four or five months
demonstrate but I thought that I was
going to end up serving out my term you
was uh serving an attorney general Jeff
Sessions so had an alarming amnesia
problem when it came to remembering his
contacts with Russians sooner or later
you were tainted by this identification
weren't you i sticking there oh sure
potentially but I thought that was my
duty the nature of the president
actually increased my commitment to stay
in my role and serve and protect the FBI
and the American people so yeah I knew
it was gonna be hard and there's gonna
be all kinds of difficult situations but
I thought what a coward I would be to
walk away from that when I was supposed
to be leading an organization that's by
spirit and culture independent we're
running out of time so I just wanted to
touch on something briefly we told that
Robert Miller the special counsel is
going to issue at least part of his
report by the end of the summer we know
the president discussed firing him at
some point he's also talked about having
the right to pardon himself not that he
says he's done anything wrong his lawyer
Rudolph Giuliani says they're gonna see
if they can have the entire
investigation declared illegal are these
the moves of somebody who's innocent are
they typical of somebody who's
who has nothing to worry about do you
think these these patterns of behavior
reflect something else I don't know what
it reflects and I believe it or not has
given my career I still don't draw the
darkest inference the fact that someone
acts this way doesn't necessarily mean
that they're guilty of something it
could just be this president's lifelong
habit of attacking attacking attacking
when he feels threatened but I don't
know what it is honestly and I think he
does feel threatened well I think his
attorney has said he and the president
said he thinks he's being attacked by a
deep state as part of a witch-hunt
that's nonsense but there's no doubt
that he feels that way in the last year
since you were father you more or less
inclined to believe that his campaign
cooperated with Russia I still don't
know I don't know I don't know what the
special prosecutor will conclude I don't
I don't but you have an opinion I don't
really I don't
yeah I'd not seen the case completed
again it began in the late part of July
in 2006 I'm a citizen I don't and here's
why I say that I'm not being silly I
know none of the things that you've
heard or I've heard in the media are
coming from the special prosecutor and
so everybody's uninformed about this
it's all speculation you said we're told
and reports coming in the summer by who
the special prosecutors run an entirely
tight ship so I don't know what he knows
and no one does actually outside of his
operation so I don't know what he'll
find and I don't think people should
care so long as he's able to find the
best view of the evidence and the truth
if he finds that I'm not rooting for a
particular outcome but I honestly don't
know what he'll find you worried when
you get back to Washington they're
coming off - you know I don't who they
is but the the I've no doubt the process
Congress no I'm not worried yeah not
worried about that at all no not even in
the slightest no no because I know the
facts I know the facts literally zero
concern on my part
they've already challenged you
your behavior oh that's the nature of
the sitting straight so you just dismiss
it you just dismiss oh no no no and
you're lumping them all together I
respect and carefully abide the views of
the inspector general the noise coming
out of here's the likely told you to get
lost
no that's not a fair characterization I
politely said to them look I respect you
people and the work you're doing I weigh
it differently I see it differently
that doesn't mean I'm right I'm never
certain I'm right especially in the
hardest decisions but I see it different
than you even in hindsight and I believe
that's okay show me another circumstance
like this because if I could have found
when I've used it as a model this was a
500 year flood and I totally respect
that people see it differently
thoughtful people the political noise
and the tweets and all that does not
bother me and is silliness silliness
James Comey thanks for being ok thanks
for having me
[Music]
you
[Music]